we want to start with joy read if you've
got a TV you may know who she is she's
the host of a weekly show on MSNBC she's
an icon on the progressive left there's
not a single fashionable opinion that
joy read doesn't have or isn't happy to
denounce you for not having she's a
total star in Brooklyn of course but she
wasn't always this way and didn't always
have these beliefs
back in 2006 joy read sounded like a
very different person on her blog at the
time she opposed gay marriage mocked gay
people and people she thought were gay
now given where she is now these are
obviously highly embarrassing opinions
to have had when the posts were
discovered she had a couple of options
she could have just apologized people
changed their opinions all the time and
good for them why wouldn't they change
their opinions America has changed is
changing so an honest explanation would
have been just fine and we would have
defended her in that of course but
that's not what Joey Reid did instead
she lied about it
she claims she never wrote those blog
posts in the first place someone else
did she said she'd been hacked sinister
agents perhaps employed by Vladimir
Putin somehow broke into her blog retro
actively to add the remarks it really
sounds like an MSNBC segment part of
what they run every night she said it
was an disinformation campaign waged by
whom we don't know shadowy forces that
was her explanation it was a crock a
total crock and we know it was a crock
because Reid's blog posts were archived
by other websites including the Library
of Congress here in Washington all the
way back to 2006 that means in order for
her claims to be true which they're not
the secret hacking plot must have begun
at least 12 years ago before anyone knew
or cared who joy read was that's a lie
it's a childish law you'd have to be a
[ __ ] to believe it yet she's telling it
here's the interesting part though NBC
News is endorsing all of this as true
and trying to convince other people it's
true yesterday the network circulated a
vague report by the extremely odd person
called Jonathan Nichols who says he's an
independent security consultant whatever
that is in which he affirms joy Reid's
ludicrous fantasy obviously he offers no
evidence
keep in mind that NBC which is passing
this out to other news organizations
claims itself to be a news organization
and news organizations are not supposed
to lie that's rule one and yet NBC
executives make a habit of lying they
lied about the Access Hollywood tape a
couple of years ago you'll remember that
tape was leaked by NBC to David Ferran
Holt at the Washington Post who was a
college friend of NBC News chief Noah
Oppenheim the goal in that leak was to
help Hillary Clinton just two days
before a presidential debate and it
helped NBC later promised to reveal how
that tape was leaked but of course we
haven't heard because they never told us
they lied instead and they're still
lying about that NBC also lied when it
ran interference for sex attacker Harvey
Weinstein which it did repeatedly over a
long period you'll remember that Network
killed ronan pharaoh's investigation
into harvey weinstein he had the goods
and yet NBC claimed that pharaoh hadn't
nailed down the story whether he went
and sold the story the next day to the
new yorker but NBC said it just wasn't
ready yet
another lie now NBC is helping joy read
lie once again and almost nobody else
the media is saying anything about it
except Michael Graham he's a columnist
for The Boston Globe earning joins us
now to tell us what exactly is going on
so look I just want to be completely
clear I am okay with people changing
their views my views on almost
everything have changed so I don't think
there's a sin in that and to come out
and say yeah I thought that I don't
think that anymore is totally fine
why would n be C endorse and ratify and
disseminate what is so clearly a false
explanation from joy read look maybe
they're just suckers I mean look how
they follow him for the Russia gate
story where every single week ago this
is a witch tree got him now we got him I
mean there's apparently nothing they
know nothing about how the internet
works apparently I think when Hillary
Clinton said that she cleaned her her
server with a cloth I think they went
okay with the closet but that's not as
you did it so maybe maybe that's it
but there is something you you make a
very good point Tucker that there's
something odd about the willingness of
NBC to stand by a story that is so
ludicrous it reminds me of a time in the
past when a another Network stood behind
by Dan Rather and when the New York
Times said that that bogus story was
fake but accurate and so what's happened
I think is
there are people who were in the quote
news business who just realized they're
not really in the news business they're
in the political advocacy business and
joy Reed is an amazing political
advocate she has a lot of fans she's
very powerful and I want to read a tweet
I don't wanna get the words wrong
apologize for my phone this is from a
Clinton staffer who tweeted out today
and then blocked me so I didn't look it
back up make sure you're evaluating this
joy in read situation through an
intersectional lens she is one of the
most important black female voices on TV
wins
she's just lying she's lying obviously
nobody went in the Wayback Machine to
2006 because uh-huh one day I know this
person will be on cable TV
I'll get them now it's nonsense but
intersectionality really is it so bad
but why I wonder why I mean most people
if they work for news organization and
got caught doing something and they went
to the boss and they said I've an idea
let's make up a patently ludicrous lie
that is provably untrue the boss would
say how about not why don't you just say
you did it
concede you did it admit it and most
people fair-minded people will kind of
forgive you and move on why would envy
see further besmirch itself by tying
itself to something so obviously false
and stupid and insulting to the rest of
us because there's a hardcore group of
people who tuned in you know it's the
wishes on the weekends so it's you know
kind of like bonus revenue and they are
there once again not for news they're
there to have their biases affirmed and
let's face it Tucker that's a problem
across the left and right media it
happens a lot and so that's why they're
there and so my Twitter feed today was
full of people who said I'm gay I'm
liberal I don't care what she said she
hates Trump she's really good at hating
chocolate if you hate Trump enough you
can do whatever you want and all sins
will be forgiven man I'm not a joy Reid
fan I mean to put it mildly she's
attacked me I think she's a race baiter
but I would have given her and any
honest person a pass if she'd been
honest which she's not by the way I
should tell our viewers that just a
minute ago The Daily Beast which is an
online blog kind of a mediocre one has
announced it's putting a pause
on joy reads columns apparently she
writes to another not surprisingly
anyway Michael Graham thanks for joining
us appreciate it thanks for having me